good morning everyone by name is Shawn
out your ta the semester for the class
10 to 13 chemical engineering
thermodynamics I am a fourth year PhD
student in the chemical engineering
department and my research is actually
really related to what you're going to
learn in this semester if you have any
question coming up you can email me and
my email address is Shawn Sh awl @
mit.edu you can always come to our
office hour if you have any questions
I'll be happy to answer any concern and
questions that you have I really hope
that we can all learn together
throughout the semester tackling all the
difficulty and challenges in this class
I hope you have a great semester and a
great learning experience and in 10 to
13
hello and welcome to 1636 communication
systems and networks my name is Marcia
and I would with your ta throughout this
semester about me I'm a second year PhD
student in aeronautics and astronautics
the horsemen and I would like to help
you if you have any question rest of the
course but I also want you to help me if
there was anything can be used if you
had any problem understanding what I
explained or related to my accent or
language barrier please let me know
other work on it and try to fix it so
the information that we need is the
office hour it would be on mondays three
to four p.m. in room 33 422 and if you
had any question other than this time
please email me at mit.edu I will try to
get back to you as soon as possible okay
so is there any question related to this
you